a couple of announcements before we get
started so first of all ps1 is out
problem set 1 it is due on 17th that's 2
weeks from today you have exactly 2
weeks to work on it you could take up to
2 or 3 late days I think you can take up
to three late days there is there's a
good amount of programming and a good
amount of math you need to do so
ps1 needs to be uploaded the solutions
need to be uploaded to great scope
you'll have to make two submissions one
submission will be a PDF file which you
can either which you can either use a
latex template that we provide or you
can handwrite it as well but you're
strongly encouraged to use the the latex
template and there is a separate coding
assignment for which you'll have to
submit code as a separate great scope
assignment so they're going to you're
going to see two assignments in great
scope one is for the written part the
others for the is for the programming
part with that let's let's jump right
into today's topics so today we are
going to cover briefly we're going to
cover the perceptron algorithm and then
you know good chunk of today is going to
be exponential family and generalized
linear models and we'll we'll end it
with softmax regression for multi-class
classification so perceptron we saw in
logistic regression so first of all the
perceptron algorithm I should mention is
not something that is widely used in
practice we study it mostly for
historical reasons oh and also because
it is it's nice and simple and you know
it's easy to analyze and we also have
homework questions on it so logistic
regression we saw logistic regression
uses the sigmoid function
right so the logistic regression user
the sigmoid function which which
essentially squeezes the entire real
line from minus infinity to infinity
between zero and one and and the zero
and one kind of represents the
probability right you could also think
of a variant of that which will be like
the perceptron where so in the in in the
sigmoid function at at z equals 0 at z
equals 0 g of z is a half and as Z tends
to minus infinity Z tends to 0 and as Z
tends to plus infinity G tends to 1 the
perceptron algorithm uses a somewhat
similar but different function which
right so G of Z in this case is 1 if Z
is greater than equal to 0 and 0 if Z is
less than 0 right so you can you can
think of this as the hard version of the
son of the sigmoid function right and
this needs to this leads to the
hypothesis function here being H theta
of X is equal to G of theta transpose X
so theta transpose X here theta is the
parameter X is the X is the input and H
state of X will be 0 or 1 depending on
whether theta transpose X was less than
0 or or greater than 0 and it all and
similarly in logistic regression we had
a H state of X is equal to essentially G
of G of Z where G is the Sigma sigmoid
function both of them have a common
update rule which on the surface looks
similar so theta J theta J plus alpha
times y minus H
right so the update rules for perceptron
and logistic regression they look the
same except each state of X means
different things in in in the two
different scenarios we also saw that it
was similar for a linear regression as
well and we're going to see why this
this is you know that this is actually a
more common common theme so what's
happening here so if you inspect this
equation to get a better sense of what's
happening in in the perceptron algorithm
this quantity over here is a scalar
right it's the difference between y i
which can be either 0 and 1 and eight
state of X I which can either be 0 or 1
right so when the algorithm makes a
prediction of each state of eight set of
X I for a given X I this quantity will
either be 0 if if the algorithm got it
right already and it will be either plus
1 or minus 1 if if Y i if the actual if
the ground truth was plus 1 and the
algorithm predicted 0 then it this will
evaluate to 1 if wrong and why I equals
1 and similarly it is minus 1 if wrong
and why I
so what's happening here to see what's
what's happening it's useful to see this
picture so this is the input space right
and let's imagine there are two two
classes boxes and let's say circles and
you want to learn I'm going to learn an
algorithm that can separate these two
classes right and if you imagine that
the what what the algorithm has learned
so far is a theta that represents this
decision boundary so this represents
theta transpose x equals zero and
anything about is theta transpose X is
greater than zero and anything below is
a transpose X less than zero right
and let's say the algorithm is learning
one example at a time and a new example
comes in and this time it happens to be
the new example happens to be a square
or a box and but the algorithm has miss
misclassified right now this line the
separating boundary if the vector
equivalent of that would be a vector
that's normal to the line so this would
be theta and this is our new X this is
the new X so this got misclassified this
R this is lying to you know lying on the
bottom of the decision boundary so what
what what's gonna happen here
weii let's call this the one class and
this is this as the zero class right so
why I minus eight state of I will be
plus one and what the algorithm is doing
is it sets theta to be theta plus alpha
times X
right so this is the old theta this is X
alpha is some small learning rate so it
adds let me use a different color here
it adds right alpha times X to theta and
now say this is let's call it theta
prime is the new vector that's that's
the updated value right and they and the
separating hyperplane corresponding to
this is something that is normal to it
yeah so so it updated the decision
boundary such that X is now included in
the positive class right the the idea
here is that theta we want theta to be
similar to X in general where such where
Y is 1 and we want theta to be not
similar to X when y equals 0 the reason
is when two vectors are similar the dot
product is positive and they are not
similar the dot product is negative what
does that mean if let's say this is X
and let's say you have theta if there
are kind of pointed outwards their dot
product would be negative and when when
if you have a theta that looks like this
Teta prime then the dot product will be
positive if their angle is less than so
this essentially means that as theta is
rotating the decision boundary is kind
of perpendicular to theta and you want
to get all the positive X's on one side
of the decision boundary and what's the
what's the most naive way of taking
theta and given X try to make theta more
and closer to X simple thing is to just
add a component of X in that direction
you know add it here and kind of make
theta and so this this is a very common
technique used in lots of algorithms
where if you add a vector to another
vector you make the second one in a
closer to the first one essentially so
this is this is the perceptron algorithm
you go example
example in an online manner and if the
example is already classified you do
nothing you get a 0 over here if it is
misclassified you either are the add a
small component of you add the vector
itself the example itself but your theta
or you subtract it depending on the
class of the vector that's about it any
questions about the perceptron cool so
let's move on to the next topic
exponential families so exponential
family is essentially a class of yeah
it's not used in practice because aid it
does not have a probabilistic
interpretation of what's what's
happening you kind of have a geometrical
feel of what's happening with with the
hyperplane but it doesn't have a
probabilistic interpretation also it's
it was in I think the perceptron was a
pretty famous and I think the nineteen
fifties or the sixties where people
thought this is a good model of how the
brain works and I think it was Marvin
Minsky who wrote a paper saying you know
the perceptron is it's kind of limited
because it it could never classify
points like this there's no possible
separating boundary that can you know do
something as simple as this and kind of
people lost interest in it but yeah and
in fact what we see is in logistic
regression is like a softer version of
the perceptron itself in a way yeah yeah
it's it's it's up to you know it's it's
a design choice that you make what you
could do is you can you can kind of
anneal your learning rate with every
step every time you see a new example
decrease your learning rate until
something until you stop changing theta
by a lot you can you're not guaranteed
that you'll you'll be able to get every
example right for example here no matter
how long you learn you're never going to
you know find a learning boundary so
it's it's up to you when you want to
stop training common things to just
decrease the learning rate with every
time step until you stop making changes
all right let's move on to exponential
families so exponential families is is a
class of probability distributions which
are somewhat nice mathematically right
they're also very closely related to
GLM's which we will be going over next
right but first we kind of take a deeper
look at exponential families and and and
what they're about so an exponential
family is one whose PDF so whose PDF can
be written in the form my PDF I mean
probability density function with a
discrete distribution then it would be
the probability mass function and this
PDF can be written in the form
right this looks pretty scary let's
let's kind of break it down into you
know what what they actually mean
so why over here is the data right and
there is a reason why we call it why
because yeah a bit larger sure
this is better so why is the data and
the reason there's a reason what we call
it Y and not X and and that's because
we're going to use exponential families
to model the output of your of your data
you know in a supervised learning
setting and and we're going to see X
when we move on to GLM's until you know
until then we're just going to deal with
Y's for now
so Y is the data it is is called the
natural parameter right T of Y is called
a sufficient statistic if you have a
statistics background and you you know
if you come across the word sufficient
statistic before it's the exact same
thing but you don't need to know much
about this because for all the
distributions that we're going to be
seeing today or in this class T of Y
will be equal to just Y so you can you
can just replace T of Y with Y for for
all the examples today and in the rest
of the of the class B of Y it's called a
base measure right and finally a of beta
is called the lock partition function
and you're going to be seeing a lot of
this function not partition function
right so again why is the data that this
probability distribution standard model
eta is the parameter of the distribution
T of Y which will mostly be just Y
technically we you know T of Y is more
more correct to B of Y which means it is
a function of only Y this function
cannot involve data right and similarly
T of Y cannot involve
data it should be purely a function of Y
B of Y is called the base measure and a
of eita which has to be a function of
only eight and constants no no Y can can
can be part of a of data it's called the
lock partition function right and the
reason why this is called the lock
partition function is pretty easy to see
because this can be written as B of Y so
these two are exactly the same just take
this out and
it's fine these are exactly the same and
oh yeah you're right this should be
positive thank you so this is you can
think of this as a normalizing constant
of the distribution such that the the
whole thing integrates to 1 right and
therefore the log of this will be a of 8
other so H is called the log of the
partition function so the partition
function is a technical term to indicate
the normalizing constant of probability
distributions now you can plug in any
definition of B a and P yep sure so why
is your Y and for most of most of our
example it's going to be a scalar
eita can be a vector but we will also be
focusing except maybe in softmax this
would be a scalar T of Y has to match so
these the dimension of these two has to
match and these are scalars right so for
any choice of a B and T that you put
that's that that can be your choice
completely as long as the expression
integrates to 1 you have a family in the
exponential family right what does that
mean for a specific choice of say for
some choice of a B and T this can
actually this will be equal to say the
PDF of the Gaussian in which case you
got for that choice of T a and and and B
you got the Gaussian distribution a
family of Gaussian distribution such
that for any value of the parameter you
get a member of the Gaussian family
right and this is mostly to show that a
distribution is in the exponential
family the most straightforward way to
do it is to write out the PDF of the
distribution in the form that you know
and just do some algebraic massaging to
bring it into this form right and then
you do a pattern match to two and you
know conclude that it's a member of the
exponential family so let's do it for a
couple of examples so a Bernoulli
distribution is one you used to model a
binary data right and it has a parameter
let's call it fee which is you know the
probability of the event happening or
not right now the what is the PDF of a
Bernoulli distribution one way to write
this is fee of Y times 1 minus V 1 minus
y make sense this this pattern is like a
way of writing a programming
programmatic if-else in in math right so
whenever Y is 1 this term cancels out so
the answer would be fee and whenever Y
is 0 this term cancels out and the
answer is 1 minus V so this is just a
mathematical way to represent an if/else
that you would do in programming right
so this is the PDF of Bernoulli and our
goal is to take this form and massage it
into that form right and and see what
what
the individual TB and a turn out to be
right
so whenever you see a distribution in
this form a common technique is to wrap
this with a log and an X because these
two cancel out so this is actually
exactly equal to this and if you do some
more algebra on this we will see that
this turns out to be XP plus it's pretty
straightforward to go from here to here
I'll let you guys verify it yourself but
once we have it in this form it's easy
to kind of start doing some pattern
matching from this expression to that
expression so what what we see here is
the base measure B of Y is equal to if
you match this with that B of Y will be
just 1 because there's no B of Y term
here and so this would be B of Y this
would be beta this would be P of Y this
would be a 8 right so that would be you
know you can see that you know that they
kind of match in pattern so B of Y would
be 1 T of Y is just Y as as expected
well so eta is equal to
log P over 1 minus P and this is an
equivalent statement is to invert this
operation and say P is equal to 1 over 1
plus e to the minus beta
I'm just flipping the operation from
this this went from fee to a tahir you
know it's it's the equivalent now here
it goes from a Tartar fee right and a of
eita
is going to be so here we have it as a
function of fee but we got an expression
for fee in terms of eita
so you can plug this expression in here
and with the change of minus sign so let
me work out the sub-sites gonna be minus
log of 1 minus P this is I just it
pattern matching there and minus log 1
minus 8 the reason is because we want an
expression in terms of eita here we got
it in terms of Phi
but we need to plug in plug in a tower
here beta and this will just be log of 1
plus e to the 8th so there we go so this
this kind of verifies that the Bernoulli
distribution is a member of the
exponential family any questions here so
note that this may look familiar
it looks like the sigmoid function
somewhat like the sigmoid function and
this is actually no accident we will see
why it is actually the sigmoid how it
kind of relates to logistic regression
in a minute so another example
so a Gaussian with fixed millions all
right so a Gaussian distribution has two
parameters the mean and the variance for
our purposes we're going to assume a
constant variance you can have you can
also consider the options with with
where the variance is also a variable
but for our course we're only interested
in gaussians with fixed variance and we
are going to assume assume variance is
equal to one so this gives the PDF of a
Gaussian to look like this P of Y
parametrized is mu so note here when we
start writing out we start with the
parameters that we are commonly used to
you know they are also called like the
canonical parameters and then we set up
a link between the canonical parameters
and the natural parameters that's part
of the massaging exercise that we do so
we're going to start with the canonical
parameters is equal to 1
/ - so this is the gaussian PDF with
with with variance equal to 1 right and
this can be rewritten as again I'm
skipping a few algebra steps you know
straightforward no tricks there yeah
our fixed variance e to the minus y
square over 2 again we go through the
same exercise you know pattern match
this is B of Y this is 8 this is T of Y
and this would be right so we have a B
of Y note that this is a function of
only why there's no eita here T of Y is
just Y and in this case a natural
parameter is mu theta is mu and the lock
partition function is equal to MU square
by 2 and when we and we repeat the same
exercise we did here we start with a
lock partition function that is
parametrized by the canonical parameters
and we use the the link between the
canonical and the natural parameters
invert it and so in this case it's the
it's the same search a tower - so a of
beta is a function of only eita
again here a of ETA was a function of
only 8 ax and T of Y is a function of
only Y and B of I is a function of
you.why as well any questions on this
yeah yeah you if the variance is unknown
you can write it as an exponential
family in which case ADA will now be a
vector it won't be a scalar in mode it
will be it will have to like eight a one
and eight or two and you will also have
you will have a mapping between each of
the canonical parameters and each of the
natural parameters you can do it it's
pretty straightforward
right so this is this is exponential
these are exponential families right the
reason why we are why we use exponential
family is because it has some nice
mathematical properties right so so one
property is now on if we perform maximum
likelihood on on the exponential family
as as when when when the exponential
family is parameterized in the natural
parameters then the optimization problem
is concave so MLE with respect to ETA is
concave similarly if you flip the sign
and use the the what's called the
negative log likelihood so take the log
of the expression negated and in in this
case the negative log likelihood is like
the cost function equivalent of doing
maximum likelihood you're just flipping
a sign instead of maximizing you
minimize the negative log likelihood so
the and and you know the NLL is there
for convex the expectation of why
what does this mean each of the
distribution we start with a of a to
differentiate this with respect to Etta
the lock partition function with respect
to a toss and you get another function
with respect to beta and that function
will is the mean of the distribution as
parameterize by a turn and similarly the
variance of y it's just the second
derivative this was the first derivative
this is the second derivative so the
reason why this is nice is because in
general for probability distributions to
calculate the mean and the variance you
generally need to integrate something
but over here you just need to
differentiate which is a lot easier
operation and and you will be proving
these properties in your first homework
you provided hint search should be
right so now we're going to move on to
generalized linear models this this is
all we want to talk about exponential
families any questions yeah exactly so
if you're if you're if you're if it's a
multivariate Gaussian then this data
would be a vector and this would be the
Hessian
all right let's move on to GLM's
so the GLM is is somewhat like a natural
extension of the exponential families to
include include covariates or include
your input features in some way right
so over here we are only dealing with in
the exponential families you're only
dealing with the Y which in our case it
will kind of map to the outputs but we
can actually build a lot of many
powerful models by by choosing an
appropriate family in the exponential
family and kind of plugging it down to a
linear model so the assumptions we're
going to make for GLM is that one so
these are the assumptions or design
choices that are going to take us from
exponential families to generalize
linear models so the most important
assumption is that well yeah assumption
is that Y given X parametrized by theta
is a member of an exponential family by
exponential family of kata I mean that
form it could it could in in a
particular scenario that you have it
could take on any one of these
distributions we only we only talked
about the Bernoulli and Gaussian there
are also other distributions that are
those are part of the exponential family
for example forgot to mention this so if
you have real valued data you use a
Gaussian
if you have binary Bernoulli if you have
counts my counts here so this is a
real-valued it can take any value
between 0 and infinity by count like
means just non-negative integers but not
anything it we need so if you have count
you can use a Poisson if you have
positive real valued integers like say
the volume of some object or the time to
an event which you know you're only
predicting into the future so here you
can use like gamma or exponential so so
there is the exponential family and
there is also a distribution called the
exponential distribution which are you
know two distinct things the exponential
distribution happens to be a member of
the exponential family as well but
they're not the same thing the
exponential and ya and you can also have
you can also have probability
distributions over probability
distributions like beta delay these
mostly show up in Bayesian machine
learning or Bayesian statistics
so depending on the kind of data that
you have if your Y variable is is is if
you're trying to do a regression then
your Y is going to be say a Gaussian if
you're trying to do a classification
then your Y is and if it's a binary
classification then the exponential
family would be Bernoulli so depending
on the problem that you have you can
choose any member of the exponential
family as parametrized by theta and so
that's the first assumption that y
condition on Y given X is a member of
the exponential family and the second
the design choice that we are making
here is that eta is equal to theta
transpose X so this is where your X now
comes into the picture right so theta is
our N and X is also in our n now this n
has nothing to do with anything in the
exponential family it's purely
dimensions of your of your data that you
have the axis of your inputs and and
this does not show up anywhere else I
mean that that's and ETA is is we we
make a design choice that Etta will be
theta transpose transpose X and another
kind of assumption is that at test time
right when we want output for a new X
given a new X we want to make an output
right so the output will be right so
given an X and given an X we get an
exponential family distribution right
and the mean of that distribution will
be the prediction that we make for a
given for a given X on this may sound a
little abstract but you know we're going
to make this more clear so this what
does essentially mean is
the hypothesis function is actually just
right this is our hypothesis function
and we'll see that you know what we do
over here if you plug in the exponential
family as Gaussian then the hypothesis
will be the same you know Gaussian
hypothesis that we saw in linear
regression if we plug in a Bernoulli
then this will turn out to be the same
hypothesis that we saw in logistic
regression and so on so one way to kind
of visualize this is
[Music]
right so one way to think of is if this
is there is a model and there is a
distribution right so the model we are
assuming it to be a linear model right
given X there is a learnable parameter
theta and theta transpose X will give
you a parameter right this is the model
and here is the distribution now the
distribution is a member of the
exponential family and the parameter for
this distribution is the output of the
linear model right this is the picture
you want to have in your mind and the
exponential family we make depending on
the data that we have whether it's you
know whether it's a classification
problem or a regression problem or a
time to end problem you would choose an
appropriate B a and T based on the
distribution of your choice right so
this entire thing and from this you can
say get the expectation of Y given theta
and this is same as expectation of Y
given theta transpose X right and this
is essentially our hypothesis function
that's exactly right
so so the question is are we training
theta two to predict the parameter of
the exponential family distribution
whose mean is the prediction that we are
going to make for Y that's that's
correct right and so this is what we do
at test time and during train time how
do we train this model so in this model
the parameter that we are learning by
doing gradient descent are these
parameters right so you're not learning
any of the parameters in the in the
exponential family we are not learning
mu or Sigma square or or eita we are not
learning this we are learning theta
that's part of the model and not part of
the distribution and the output of this
will become the the distributions
parameter it's unfortunate that we use
the word parameter for this and that but
there there it's important to understand
what what is being learned during
training phase and and what's not so
this parameter is the output of a
function it's not it's not a variable
that we that we do gradient descent on
so during learning what we do is maximum
likelihood maximized with respect to
theta right so you're doing gradient
ascent on the locked probability of of Y
where the the natural parameter was Reap
aramet rised with a linear model right
and we are doing gradient descent by
taking gradients on theta right the this
like the big picture of what's happening
with GLM's and how they kind of are an
extension of exponential families yuri
parameterize the parameters with a
linear model and you get a GL m
so let's let's look at some more detail
on what happens at train time
so another kind of incidental benefit of
using
GLM's is that a train time we saw that
we want to do maximum likelihood on the
log problem using the log probability
with respect to theta right now
at first it may appear that you know we
need to do some more algebra figure out
what the expressions for you know P is
represented in the in as a function of
theta transpose X and take the
derivatives and you know come up with a
gradient update rule and so on but it
turns out that no matter which what kind
of GLM you are doing no matter which
choice of distribution that you make the
learning update rule is the same the
learning update rule is theta you guys
have seen this so many times by now so
this is you can you can straight away
just apply this learning rule without
ever having to do any more algebra to
figure out what the gradients are or
what the what the loss is you can go
straight to the update rule and do your
learning you plug in the appropriate H
theta of X you plug in the appropriate H
theta of X depending on the choice of
distribution that you make and you can
start learning initialize your theta to
some random values and and and you can
start learning so any question on this
yeah
you can do if you want to do it for
batch gradient descent then you just sum
over all your examples yeah so the
Newton method is is is probably the most
common you would use with GLM's and that
again comes with the assumption that
your dimensionality of your data is not
extremely high as long as the number of
features is less than a few thousand
then you can do Newton's method
any other question cool so so this is
the same update rule for any any any
specific type of GLM based on the choice
of distribution that you have whether
you are modeling you know you're doing
classification whether you doing
regression whether you're doing you know
a Poisson regression the update rule is
the same you just plug in a different
age state of X and you get your learning
rule another some more terminology so
eta is what we call the natural
parameter
so eta is the natural parameter and the
function that links a natural parameter
to the mean of the distribution and this
has a name it's called the canonical
response function right and similarly
you can also let's call it mu it's like
the mean of the distribution similarly
you can go from me back to ETA with the
inverse of this and this is also called
the canonical link function there's some
terminology we also already saw that G
of eta is also equal to the the the
gradient of the law partition function
with respect to theta so side not G
right and it's also helpful to make
explicit the distinction between the
three different kinds of
parameterizations we have so we have
three parameterizations so we have the
model parameters that's theta the
natural parameters that's 8 and we have
the canonical parameters and this is a
fee for Bernoulli mu and Sigma square
for Gaussian lambda for Poisson so these
are three different ways we are we can
parameterize either the exponential
family or the GLM and whenever we are
learning a GLM it is only you know this
thing that we learn right that is the
theta in the linear model this is the
theta that is that is learnt right and
the connection between these two is is
linear so theta transpose X will give
you the natural parameter and this is
the design choice that we are making and
we choose to reaper ammeter is a 2 by a
linear model a linear of a linear in
your data and between these two you have
G to go this way G inverse come back
this way where G is also the derivative
of the partition so yeah so it's
important to to kind of realize it can
get pretty confusing when you're seeing
this for the first time because you have
so many parameters that are being
swapped around and you know getting
repairmen tries there are three kind of
spaces in which three different ways in
which we are parameterizing or
generalized
your models the model parameters the
ones that we learn and the output of
this with this the natural parameter for
the exponential family and you can you
know do some algebraic manipulations and
get the canonical parameters for the
distribution that we are choosing
depending on the task whether it's
classification or regression any
questions on this
so now it's actually pretty you know you
can see the you know when you're doing
logistic regression right so each theta
of X so H state of X is the expected
value of y condition and this is equal
to V because here the choice of
distribution is a Bernoulli and the mean
of a Bernoulli distribution is just V
the in the in the canonical parameter
space and if we write that as in terms
of t minus theta transpose X so the
logistic function which when we
introduced linear logistically agression
we just you know pulled out the logistic
function out of thin air and said hey
this is something that can squash minus
infinity to infinity between 0 and 1
seems like a good choice but but now we
see that it is it is a natural outcome
it just pops out from this more elegant
generalized linear model where if you
choose Bernoulli to be to be the
distribution of your output then you
know the logistic regression just just
pops out naturally so
[Music]
any questions yeah yeah so the the
choice of what distribution you're going
to choose is really dependent on the
task that you have so if your task is
regression where you want to output real
valued numbers like price of the house
or something then you choose a
distribution over the real real numbers
like a Gaussian if your task is
classification that your output is
binary 0 or 1 you choose a distribution
that models binary data right so the
task in a way influences you to pick the
distribution and you know most of the
times that choice is pretty obvious if
you want to model the number of visitors
to a website which is like a count you
know you want to use a Poisson
distribution because Poisson
distribution is a distribution over
integers so the task decide you know
pretty much tells you what distribution
you want to choose and then you you do
the you know you do this you know all
you you go through this machinery of
figuring out what are the what what a
trait of X is and you plug in each state
of X over there and you have your
learning role any more questions so it
so we made some assumptions these
assumptions now it's it's also helpful
to kind of get a visualization of what
these assumptions actually mean
so to expand upon your point you know if
you think of the question are GLM's used
for classification or are they used for
regression or are they used for you know
something else
the answer really depends on what is the
choice of distribution that you're going
to choose you know GLM's are just a
general way to model data and that data
could be you know binary it could be
real valued and as long as you have a
distribution that can model that kind of
data and falls in the exponential family
it can be just plugged in to a GL m and
everything just works out nicely so so
the assumptions that we made well let's
start with regression right so for
aggression we assume there is some X to
simplify I'm I'm drawing X as one
dimension but you know X could be
multi-dimensional and there exists a
theta right and theta transpose X would
would be some linear some linear
hyperplane and this we assume is beta
right and in case of regression eight I
was also mu so eight I was also mu and
then we are assuming that the Y for any
given X is distributed as a Gaussian
with mu as the mean so which means for
every X every possible X you have the
appropriate data and with this as the
mean let's let's think of this as Y so
there is a Gaussian distribution at
every possible
we assume a variance of one so this is
like a Gaussian with standard deviation
or variance equal to one right so for
every possible X there is a Y given X
which is parameterized by by by theta
transpose X s as the mean right and you
assume that your data is generated from
this process right so what does it mean
it means given X and let's say this is y
so you would have examples in your
training set that may look like this the
Assumption here is that for every X
there is let's say for this particular
value of x there was a Gaussian
distribution that started from with a
mean over here and from this Gaussian
distribution
this value is sampled right you're just
sampling it from from the distribution
now the this is how your data is
generated again this is our assumption
right now that now based on these
assumptions what we're doing with the
GLM is we start with the data we don't
know anything else we make an assumption
that there is some linear model from
which the data was was generated in this
format and we want to work backwards
right to find theta that will give us
this line right so for a different
choice of theta we get a different line
right we assume that you know if that
line represents the the Meuse or the
means of the Y's for that particular X
from which it's sampled from we are
trying to find a line which is which
will be like your theta transpose x from
which these Y's are most likely to have
samples that that's essentially what's
happening when you do maximum likelihood
with with with the GLM similarly
similarly for classification again let's
assume there's an X right and there's
some theta transpose X right and and
this theta transpose X is equal to his
data we assign this to be later right
and this data is from this a table we we
run this through the sigmoid function 1
over 1 plus e to the minus beta to get
fee right so if these are the a TAS for
each for each a tar we run it through
the sigmoid and we get something like
this right so this tends to 1 this tends
to 0 and when at this point when eita is
0 the sigmoid is is 0.5 and now at each
point at any given choice of X we have a
probability distribution in this case
it's a it's a binary so let's assume
probability of Y is the height till the
sigmoid line and here it is so every X
we have a different Bernoulli
distribution essentially that's obtained
where you know the probability of Y is
there is the height to the sigmoid
through the natural parameter and from
this you have a data generating
distribution that would look like so X
and you have a few X's in your training
set and for those X's you calc you
you know why distribution is and sample
from it so let's say
right and now again our goal is to stop
given given this data so over here this
is the X and this is y so this is these
are points for which Y is 0 these are
points for which Y is 1 and so given
given this data we want to work
backwards to find out you know what
theta was what's the theta that would
have resulted in sigmoid like curve from
which these these Y's were most likely
to have been sampled that's and and
figuring out that Y is is is essentially
doing logistic regression any questions
alright so in the last ten minutes or so
we will go over softmax regression
so softbox aggression is so in the
lecture notes softmax regression is
explained as as yet another member of
the GLM family however in today's
lecture we'll be taking a non GLM
approach and kind of seeing and see how
softmax is is essentially doing what's
also called as cross entropy
minimization we'll end up with the same
same formulas and equations you can you
can go through the GLM interpretation in
the notes
it's a little messy to kind of do it on
the whiteboard so whereas this has it
has a nicer interpretation and it's good
to kind of get this cross-entropy
interpretation as well so let's assume
so here we are talking about multi-class
classification so let's assume we have
three cat three classes of data let's
call them circles squares and triangles
now if here you know this is x1 and x2
this just you're just visualizing your
input space and the output space Y is
kind of implicit in the shape of this so
on so in multik like a multi-class
classification our goal is to start from
this data and learn a model that can
given a new data point you know make a
prediction of whether this point is a
circle square or a triangle right you're
just looking at three because it's easy
to visualize but this can work over
thousands of classes and so what we have
is so you have x i's in RN
right so the label y is zero okay so K
is the number of classes so the labels Y
is a one hot vector what would you call
it as a one hot vector where it's a
vector which indicates which class the X
corresponds to so each each element in
the vector corresponds to one of the
classes so this may correspond to the
triangle class circle class square class
or maybe something else so the labels
are in this one hot vector where we have
a vector that's filled with zeros except
with a one in one of the places and the
way we're going to the very gonna think
of softmax regression is that each class
has its its own set of parameters so we
have theta class and and there are K
such things where class so in logistic
regression we had just one theta which
would do a binary you know yes versus no
in softmax we have one such vector of
theta per class right so you could also
optionally represent them as a matrix I
just an N by K matrix where you have a
theta class right so in softmax
regression it's it's a generalization of
logistic regression where you have a set
of parameters per class right and we're
going to do something
something similar to
so
so corresponding to each each class of
parameters there exists so there is that
exists this line which represents say
theta triangle transpose x equals zero
and anything to the left will be theta
triangle transpose X is greater than
zero and over here to be less than zero
right so if for for the theta triangle
class there is there is this line which
which corresponds to theta transpose x
equals zero anything to the left will
give you a value greater than zero
anything to the right similarly there is
also so this corresponds to theta square
transpose x equals zero anything below
will be greater than zero anything above
will be less than zero similarly you
have another one for this corresponds to
theta circle transpose x equals zero and
this half plane we have to be greater
than zero to the left is less than zero
right so we have a different set of
parameters per class which which
hopefully satisfies this property and
now our goal is to take these parameters
and let's see what happens when we feed
a new example so given an example X we
get a set of
given X and who are here we have classes
right so we have the circle class the
triangle class the square class right so
over here we plot theta class transpose
X so we may get something that looks
like this so let's say for a new point x
over here if that's our new X we would
have theta transpose theta transfer data
square transpose X to be positive so
right and maybe for for the others we
may have some negative and maybe
something like this for this right so
this piece is it's also called the logic
space I mean so these are real numbers
this will this will this is not a value
between 0 & 1 this is between plus
infinity and minus infinity right and
and our goal is to get a probability
distribution over the classes and in
order to do that we perform a few steps
so we exponentiate the logits which
would give us now it is x buff theta
class transpose x and this will make
everything positive
squares triangles and circles right now
we got a set of positive numbers and
next we normalize this my normalize I
mean divide everything by the sum of all
of them so here we have theta e to the
theta at class transpose x over some of
I in triangle square circle e to the
theta I transpose X so once we do this
operation we now get a probability
distribution
where the sum of the heights will add up
to one so so given so if given a new
point X and we run through this pipeline
we get a probability output over the
classes for which class that example is
most likely to belong to right and this
whole process so let's call this P hat
of Y for the given X right so this is
like our hypothesis the output of the
hypothesis function will output this
probability distribution in the other
cases the output of the hypothesis
function generally output a scalar or a
probability in this case it's outputting
a probability distribution over all the
classes and now the true why would look
something like this right let's say the
point over there was let's say it was a
triangle for whatever reason right if
that was the triangle then the P of Y
which is also called the label you can
think of that as a probability
distribution which is one over the
correct class and 0 elsewhere right so P
of Y this is essentially representing
the one heart representation as a
probability distribution right now the
goal or the learning approach that we
are going to do is in a way minimize the
distance between these two distributions
right this is one distribution this is
another distribution we want to change
this distribution to look like that
distribution right and and technically
that the term for that is minimize the
cross entropy between the two
distributions
so the cross-entropy between P and P hat
is equal to 4y in circle angle square P
of Y times y I don't think we will have
time to go over the interpretation of
cross-entropy but you can so here we see
that P of Y will be 1 for just one of
the classes and 0 for the others so
let's say in this say this example P of
Y will say a triangle so this will
essentially boil down to P and we saw
that this hypothesis is essentially and
on this you you treat this as the loss
and do gradient descent gradient descent
with respect to the parameters right
yeah with that I think any questions on
softmax
okay so we will break for today in that
is thanks